all right did it should I do something I
don't know like a t-shirt by the way hey
what a cottage go from you know what we
should do what college vote and then
change difficulties expert okay
you can't call any votes so soon after
the last all right you have to call them
oh I'll do it okay although thank you
why did you forget anything you're not a
book oh yes German do not journalists
all those shots yeah
oh look at this hang on take this crying
I'm flaming now
Oh explosive thing now is this guy doing
likes explode like he's wanted to say
something before you die know what's who
did you shoot I know right what shot
what is it done I didn't know what you
did oh no what's going on
Joey I got this okay I got this well
you're good Oh what am i what are you
nine moving yellow gray I get open this
side and I try to resurrect you
I'm Jonah right behind us my got me get
him I got a I got a gun Jack I
yeah I'm I'm dying
oh damn it's okay try that again
wait I this is outside all right she get
him we should get him going for him look
I always said thing would happen he oh
uh what he was up there nice shut-eye
what're you doing in here lay down and
sleep
ha ha ha Jack I got your back
I got cuz you want these pills yes I
want and drugs you can have them
thank you cry I do enjoy myself simple
ism I know I can punch people instead
hey there's a witch yeah that's fine I'm
gonna go say hi I can punch people
hi oh that's the hot air doing that's my
uh which I'm flying happening cute
alright keep moving not under by me I
was amazing okay by me I was kidding I
was kidding I'm saying I don't wanna die
we're good um a bug is the best thing
ever
this is the best did you go down next
times I see how it looks like was so
amazing I got here wait second there's
some exclusive Browns all right I can do
that
batteries I like these oh you pick up
with F that's why I'm so confused
oh that's stupid start some wild alright
here we go
I like this SMG it's pretty cool a
Boomer bile hey bubbles no way it was
just normal picture okay you want your
boom ba-ba-boom sky bumpy I want boom ba
boom ba ba ba ba ba
a lipoma oh I hear boom on the tangi
boom bah
hey we're not here hey they're not that
much ah yeah then why did you put it
there
uh whatever they're running into the
fight tip advantage Oh Brad in there
zombies yeah that's right you better run
into the fire hi
let's go rocket oh no he's thrown the
wall yeah I noticed that too I thought
it was boobs man and she's she's great
we could copy our buddy
oh but if they don't want to copy the
bus okay
it is the other door here cold drinks I
like drinks huh meatza
joy can we buy them with money no I
wouldn't have money crash I can't get
over at the squall go there's Thor okay
that's good I don't have a thickener a
this is a custom map of every day - by
the way I forgot to mention that oh yeah
no this is totally an official map made
by gaben all himself yeah Gabe Newell
made it yes he voiced all the monsters
mother - that would make sense
what are you how they you I I am over
here oh he's on fire literacy coos oh
there's the safe house
oh that's not safe at all see it's all
red in here
what oh you're behind me oh I saw the
Python where is it
my people are bomb oh yeah we should
clear like this Jackie tick tick tick
tick tick what are you doing I did it I
have to do everything here do I have
this go that's a good way to pave that I
thought of me
hey refrigerator boom boom boom boom
boom
ah oh you got the Pumas on me i-it's
okay
don't worry
son of a [ __ ] I'm got it it's fine
that's fine crash boots s fine it's all
the time I'm hoping you're going down
second watch you I am going to be
professional
sir I cyan inches oh you Mets it you
wanted me to go down no I got boomer you
want the boomer bah
Oh bull I know it's my boom you put them
to move I'm all right I'm charging my
boomer by okay okay go Chuck the boom
bah bah yeah I'm gonna check eyes acidic
Oz Krause all right it's perfect
I got a big following Chopra did it oh
they dropped the freaking again somebody
[ __ ] here Oh bitters dropped to freakin
explosive Oh
oh yeah they drop items on a smoker
smuggle you're smoking nipple
oh don't worry back right don't worry
oh my Becca wait I had to throw a pipe
bomb oh I'm sorry
all right go Kay all right I'm going
kill him let me open that for you cry oh
wait no I shot the car not [ __ ] I shot
the guy all right oh [ __ ] him up
why did I shut the car why did I get
backup
live in [ __ ] some ah Molly [ __ ] Lou
to get [ __ ] PI po PI po PI po PI po
venison down down
how about here [ __ ] out of you stop
following no no we didn't even make it
to the safe house
hey I get this and then I tell you what
no and then you kill me kill me okay
Sheldon did your app tell you our
changes
why are you freezing all right all right
should make [ __ ] me should me okay Jimmy
should make sure I get you
samurai shout stop reviving crime [ __ ]
me oh how did you die no not part of the
plan and think you would diet you are
going to get we were going to kill each
other so we both would slide around in
that awesome mode you get it I know you
[ __ ] die that's saving everyone - out
all right well pull Russ what what that
put you through the through a wall there
through the window
whoa what an amazing I gotta Molly look
say well your Molly's that booming all
right nice shiny let's run through the
fiery have these things oh that's what
you gotta have fine it's fine that's
fine no it's fine Oh told you it wasn't
fun yeah got that iron stack up that's
okay
I'll be on my way now nobody you
underestimate me
I know you got my gosh let's go
you got this I haven't got a help I
don't
I got this here at this ha Thank You Man
hey Christmas Merry fun bear oh there's
a spirit goobers don't worry about it
let's just finish this map alright we
gotta win this a bull Russian hold on
I'm leaving you for dead no mrs. Russian
okay I'm leaving you for dead call left
for dead after all
yeah no god I'm gonna get for dead
worried about me um be okay Shh don't
leave me for dead bra all right fine I
won't leave you every day I'm just gonna
leave you for back up back up back and
the Kilis wounded which has a big eared
we're not it's Anna Wintour that way
don't touch cry son even I look bad Sami
bad zombie Oh
Franza these are to throw Sookie not
working Freddie
I've looked up the gifts particularly
I'm sayin ma'am how's it going what's up
you'll you incoming panic event yeah
Gemma cry oh [ __ ] there's somebody Oh
market say really [ __ ] good cry
you're amazing Maya don't [ __ ] tell
you [ __ ] get over this way don't
think about think about okay [ __ ] I'm
leg left for dead heavy kept edition or
something oh [ __ ] come on come on come
on
I hear the witch right this is where we
were the last time pretty much I have a
Molotov I have um explosive and I have a
molecule I have a truck that's red and
it's not technically mine but it's in
front of me it's now ours please don't
shoot cars up oh yeah I shut the car
last time that's what I did yeah don't
do that
don't shoot the car shut up whoa she's
ready for some luck oh don't shoot the
car I I don't shoot the car let's check
this out alright let's check it off ah
smoking you got you smell gum no not by
the car cry
no fighting cuz it's there's a tank does
it take yeah we're fine okay why am i
down I went down right what why am i
down dammit it's gonna be one of those
heavy edited videos I don't know
witches appeared don't worry about her I
will peirong up hills run okay I'm Kevin
[ __ ] she come
No mmm that way bike huh okay
ah this is where we're so many oh I got
huh I got counts on both your heads okay
no loading will be fine yeah not fun
okay I'm using their what is it tank
still here no crowding why did you do it
anyway alright your charger I should
kill me what did you do no no way I'm
coming to save you cry don't worry about
it how to save you
hey hey big guy good boy
can't kill zombie shallowed [ __ ] and I
have these you want these you can handle
of it you dropped your health back wait
I I did I did
oh look an oak regular I just know a
Mogan
it's months what yes
you got you yeah you still up there oh I
think we need to go to the red subway
yeah go let's go ahead freaking okay
dick wiki do it we're doing it charge it
with my ex get a chrome shotgun Oh
Isaiah oh I got the chrome shotgun - no
you don't a boom boom boom boom I got
him as if I got him
wait if I got him you're right but a big
I'm proud again
right on my five years out stop what
this is which while it's not even
possible this may like me so which is
biznitch in life Rochelle's left behind
Rochelle yep she's left for dead semi
fine yep it's not error era that's a
good thing that's that's a good knife
ladder right it's the new special
effects ladder yeah it's a good ladder
yeah yeah coach I left this [ __ ] coach
oh let's do this good yes
I didn't shoot you I did yep we'll be
fun did I hear someone startling a which
I've wig look we're at the safe room
switch what's your third lie which I
didn't do that I sterner we win it
[ __ ] finally God having coach you're
better than us she'll do better than oh
man I didn't even know man but bro day
every day I don't bring no can you do an
outro I can do them of ultra of darkness
then redness then white is sweet wrong
guy [ __ ] I'll do an outer of darknessand
red redness this bro has browsers better
out yeah sure mode activate right where
are you
I ran back what ok I'm right back guys
don't lose me now oh wait I'm playing
with zombies
try come and the [ __ ] [ __ ]